finale the climax of my performance you
see this was my dream so the dynamic duo
has finally arrived to call on the Joker
to drop in gentlemen I the notorious
Joker will stage the biggest ripoff in
the history of Gotham City the
superpowers old headquarters who will
soon be our new base on earth oh don't
you love the irony jack is dead my
friend you can call me
Jagger and as you can see I'm a lot
happier first thing tomorrow I'm sending
a lovely case of cat food to Batman
truth be told strings never were my
section
I'm much better on the keys
you'll need to tell me the key for
police considers this vigilante a
greater menace than the Clown Prince of
Crime anyway long story short bit bummed
come on Reds dead you too
don't trouble your feathers I have a
permanent solution for these meddling
kids turns to me anything why so serious
he comes at me with the knife why so
serious
sticks the blade in my mouth
what's but a smile on that face
I'll need some guys not these guys
because well they're kind of dead ladies
and gentlemen we interrupt your
regularly scheduled mayhem to bring you
this important announcement that's all
right I want people to get me all right
then that's why I'm gonna kill everyone
in this room ha ha all that chit chats
gonna get the chair I can't wait to show
you munch toy
you
you